[Music]
we're having a few technical
difficulties with the links with harris
faulkner in this new normal we're all
living in i'm jonathon hut now stepping
in for harris and i want to continue the
conversation with House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy he is back with us as you
can see from the North Lawn of the White
House mr. McCarthy this is a difficult
situation for every business obviously
across the country is there a sense
though that the wrong businesses are
getting the money from this stimulus
we've seen these big businesses which
clearly have millions and millions of
dollars in the bank and some very small
businesses saying we're not seeing
anything and we want to make sure that
accountability and any time that that
slides through stops the latest numbers
that we find more than 74 percent or the
349 billion that has gone out has gone
to small businesses that have $60,000 in
payroll or less I have personal stories
from my own hometown of small businesses
calling me thanking because it was able
to bring people back they have laid off
but I know there's 700,000 more small
businesses sitting out there that need a
loan and those that still have to apply
we were able to move the equivalent of
what SBA has done for 14 years in 14
days we want to make sure accountability
that those that have gone through and
done something wrong in the system they
give that back and that's what the
Secretary of Treasury is actually doing
I'm just talking to him and the
president about this and they're making
sure the accountability if somebody does
something they are not we want to bring
that back because this is designed only
for small business and congressman we're
also seeing if I can switch to another
subject more and more protests popping
up across the country against the
continued closure of the American
economy demonstrators calling for those
lockdowns to be lifted in some cases it
seems to me that the demonstrators are
not obeying the social distancing laws
so are they doing the right
the wrong thing here well everybody has
a right to protest but you should
protest in a manner that you do have
social distancing we should also have
plans for how we open the country back
up and that's going to be different by
state by county and that's what we need
to work together I sent a letter to
Speaker Pelosi and I talked to her for
more than an hour today on ideas of
where we can start to open up Congress
as well you don't want to open it all at
once you want to go phase in from
committees and others and we want to do
it in a healthy safe manner just as you
can do across the country and every area
will be different so that's what we want
to work together and at all times
even when it opens back up you want to
keep that social distancing of where we
go we know a lot more about this virus
than we knew more than even a month ago
we also know that it didn't come from
here but we're going to do it we're
going to defeat this together unless all
work together in that manner and
overcome whatever obstacle we see I'm
spine already Leader Kevin McCarthy stay
with us you I and the rest of the world
will be happy to know that harris
faulkner is back with us i'll hand it
back to you Harris Jonathan I appreciate
that it was great to co-host with you
for a couple of seconds and to the
Minority Leader you are the most patient
person on the planet today so thank you
technologically we are back together so
I want to just step back for a second I
was able to watch yeah couldn't hear all
of it that was part of the problem but
let's talk just about those companies
you were talking about who gained access
to some of that small business loan
money I mean that the numbers are pretty
staggering DMC global well it was in
excess of a hundred million dollars
let's just call it receiving aid having
market values of that these were big
companies Fiesta Restaurant Group and
some others is there any sort of
punitive thing that you could do tax
wise on the back look they followed the
legislation the way it was written I get
that but they had to have known really
I'm gonna get this much money back Shake
Shack giving their ten million back is
there something on the back end if they
don't give money back that you maybe tax
them at a you know a higher rate for a
period of time to recoup some of that
what's being talked about to make it
fair we will give them the opportunity
to give it back it was not designed for
those companies to be able to acquire
this money this is
for businesses small business 500 or
fewer as you talked about that money
that went out to them overwhelmingly the
money went to the right people
the challenge was it's so popular and
remember what we're doing we're dealing
with something in a crisis creating
something we have not before and you
look at 74% of that to businesses that
have a payroll less than 60,000 and what
is what is it's designed to do is to pay
people keep people employed even when
government told you your business need
to be shut down more than 60% of this
money went out from small banks banks
that had 10 billion or less in assets
and remember we started with 1,800 banks
now we're over 5,000 so overwhelmingly
this program is working that's why more
people are applying but if if you are an
instance that you went through that you
should not have gotten this money we
will give you an opportunity because
America should come together and work
together give that back to what it how
much time do they have to give that
money back well I will tell you this
talking to the president they have a
very short timetable to give it back and
they don't have I know we will okay good
to see you today thank you so very much
for going with the flow
appreciate your time it's good to have
you back